[Music]
justin starts us off this hour in moore
oklahoma hi justin how are you
hey dave how are you doing great how can
chris and i help
well i'm a little bit frustrated and a
little bit discouraged so i'm back on
baby step 2 as of about 10 months ago
i ended up selling a car last month for
4 500
that had 250 000 miles on it and i
bought a cheaper car
an 1800 car from a neighbor got it all
checked out at the mechanic my dad is
good with cars he
got it all checked out for me looked
like a really promising deal
um got a thousand dollar or a thousand
miles down the road and the transmission
went out
that's gonna cost me uh twenty eight
hundred dollars to replace this
transmission
not in an 18 hour car
and uh my other car now has a
coolant leak and so i have to get that
checked because i was driving down the
road today
and it started overheating so i put some
coolant in it and i'm taking it to the
mechanic
i'm just sick and tired of cars that are
breaking down on me and repairs that i'm
having to do
and i'm so close to being out of debt i
only have two thousand dollars of some
student loans with my wife's
and four hundred dollars of just
consumer debt we uh have a household
income of sixty two thousand dollars and
we've been dumping
six hundred dollars minimum on debt
every month so i'm
so close to being done with that that
these cars are just wearing me out
and keep on setting me behind so i'm
wondering if you have any advice for me
man i'm sorry you are you are right
there
in the battle i mean you got bullets
flying all around you
and you are charging the hill to take
the hill
you're a warrior man and it but it gets
you get weary don't you
especially freaking cars cars make me
more mad and
weary than just about anything else i i
know this has been the thing recently
i mean my old honda that i i mean it was
just repair after repair after repair
and repair i'm like come on can i please
just get ahead
just just one time give me a break here
car angel yeah you know
you know it makes you want to take up
firearms and just shoot the crap out of
them right
that's it i've thought about that more
than once hey that 1800
that 1800 run without a transmission is
a candidate i'm just saying okay
he's a high-end nominee buddy yes
[Laughter]
yeah hey man i i i feel your pain
um and i i don't blame you
um i will tell you that that
uh the people that i've walked with and
also when sharon and i
were doing these exact same things i've
had those exact same feelings
um this is like um your breakthrough
moment emotionally and character-wise
that's going to set you up to win the
rest of your life it's like
it's like god is saying this is a test
of the emergency car sucks program
and um we're gonna see if you can suck
it up and push on through
just a little bit further because you're
near the end and it's like the devil's
trying to trip you right before you get
to the finish line
and so you can do this and you're going
to be really glad
you did it it is very hard
and it is unbelievably draining and it
is very frustrating though i will
i will give you all of that but i will
also tell you
that by god pushing through is worth it
it's worth it man because there's
another side to this the sun will come
out tomorrow
his mercies are new every morning
there's another side to this
and the other side of that is one year
from the day where are you going to be
sitting
you can tell me the math
you're going to be sitting in two much
better cars
that are paid for and 100 debt free and
you'll probably have your emergency fund
in place
one year from today but you got to
struggle through one more piece of crap
car you got to shoot the 1800 one go
find you another garage sale car
to limp on out of the 2000 and then and
the other 400 and then limp on up into
the emergency fund
and then go by god the first order of
businesses i'm gonna save some money and
get some decent cars
that's exactly right justin and the next
time the next challenge an obstacle that
comes
watch how you deal with it so you're
gonna have some experience under your
belt
you know that real the things that you
desire are going to come easy they're
just worthwhile baby
so you keep pushing you stay focused on
this
resist the urge to roll up on a lot and
grab a payment we're not going backwards
this is the point when people hit where
you are right now
that they turn left and go crazy
yep and go lease a 20 000 car
and it's all cause they just get so
pissed off they can't breathe
and they lose hope and they lose energy
and no pun intended but their gas tank
is empty
right yeah and and so i appreciate you
calling i
what i want to do is first i want you to
hear
that it would be normal to be mad in
this situation be normal to be heard
it'd be
normal to be limping you've been in
battle
yeah you've been swinging the sword man
i mean and you got some cuts and you got
some bruises
but the other thing is that the you know
you're either going to lose the battle
after getting this close
or you're going to come out the other
side and own the whole freaking thing
and that's you you're going to come out
the other side you're going to fill your
tank back
up you're going to breathe and go one
year from today
this is all going to be over and will
never freaking
go back one thing about me having driven
that old piece of car
crap car that was a friend of mine
loaned me i didn't even own it
it was a cadillac the predominant color
was bondo
at 478 000 miles on it it wasn't an 1800
car it was an 18 car and
caught i was driving it into my
neighborhood cops are following me
because they couldn't figure out what
that car was doing in my neighborhood
you know i got profile based on my car
and uh so one thing about that is i can
still feel that in my guts you can hear
it coming on my voice right now i still
remember that
it was freaking 30 years ago and so when
somebody [ __ ] about me driving a nice
car
oh you know what i say kiss my butt
because i paid a price to get there
right
yeah i drove the hoopty i drove like no
one else now i can drive like no one
else and you don't like it
kiss my butt justin if you're not
watching on youtube i wish you could see
how riled up ramsay is right now
he has literally gone back to exactly
where you are
that moment of being just tired of it
and and i'm going to tell you something
i can't wait you're going to have the
same kind of story buddy
yeah you're going to call us and do your
debt-free screenings yes you are and
then you're going to get you some dadgum
decent cars so you have to drive crap
around anymore i don't blame you man
i don't blame you firearms should be
involved in the disbursement of the 1800
i'm just saying
hey justin stay focused buddy hey you
know what i didn't do
i didn't take any pictures of that
cadillac
take pictures of that that 1800 that was
going gonna be a good car that didn't
make it a freaking thousand miles
it's part of the story you tell your
grandkids and you need the picture
yeah you do before you shoot it before
you blow it up with dynamite
take pictures of it to remember so you
can tell your grandkids yeah back in the
day
drove that me and your great grandpa
bought this car for eighteen hundred
dollars and it didn't make it a freaking
thousand miles you'll be telling it when
they're sitting on your knees someday
man
when you are winning because you're
winning at that point you built wealth
you become a millionaire that's where
you're going you got this